und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend gute namen der wanderzirkus
spd hat seine tournee beendet
er enthält über 8000 sagen wir
bahnkilometer sind sie durchs land
gereist in 23 städten haben sich die
bewerber innen teams um den
parteivorsitz der basis gestellt es war
freundlich konstruktiv sachlich und
ergebnislos die zahl der bewerber ist
nicht mehr wesentlich geschrumpft kein
favoriten team hat sich herausgestellt
es ist leicht sich darüber jetzt lustig
zu machen aber ab montag wird ja gewählt
und eines der paare wird dann gewinnen
und dann ist die entscheidung da
entstanden in einem mit anstand auf
offener bühne geführten wettbewerb das
ist was in diesen zeiten klaus brodbeck
war dabei der letzte auftritt nummer 23
schlusspunkt münchen und eine
überraschung dass du dass die spd am
weitesten nach links verschieben wollte
gibt auf wir machen den weg frei um die
erfolgsaussichten einer linken
spitzenkandidatur zu erhöhen liebe
genossinnen und genossen
[Applaus]
eine vorentscheidung ist es nicht die
positionen aller anderen verändert wir
wollen endlich die schwarzen null
beenden weil wir mehr investitionen im
bezahlbaren wohnraum in den klimaschutz
und in den sozialen zusammenhalt unseres
landes brauchen
ich finde wir müssten manchmal mit
unserem koalitionspartner so kannte ich
umgehen wie wir das untereinander getan
haben an vielen stellen
auf geht s gegen die gruppe und damit
oft gegen ihn was wäre wenn wenn etwa
das andere duo ganz links die koalition
beenden könnte wir brauchen alle die
hier sitzen also tatsächlich zum
beispiel bei der inneren sicherheit ist
können wir nicht auf dich verzichten
bei finanzfragen werden wir auf dich
zurückgreifen müssen
alle gegen auf wie geht sie in dublin
ich habe den eindruck nicht das ist hier
eine ganz spannende debatte jedes mal
macht diese versammlung habe ich das
gefühl wir sind alle nicht zufällig in
einer partei es ist ein kampf um die
spitze und zugleich und die zukunft der
spd einen gewinner gibt schon ist die
spd denn man sieht ja die halle ist
rappelvoll die menschen sind
leidenschaftlich daran interessiert die
spd wieder nach oben zu bringen und sie
kriegen hier viel gemeinsamkeiten aber
auch klare unterschiede zwischen den
teams ich glaube ja weil die damit den
wählern zeigen und den bären zeigen dass
wir lebendig sind dass wir eine gute
debattenkultur haben dass wir
miteinander gut umgehen können und ich
wie sie den eindruck bis wahlen gemacht
hat nur schlecht ich glaube dass alleine
schon wichtigen signal an die wähler 23
regionalkonferenzen 20.000 teilnehmer
430.000 mitglieder
sie haben nun die wahl eigentlich haben
alle eine stärke und es ist wirklich
eine schwierige wahl also man muss
wirklich unter sehr sehr guten aussehen
der prozess hilft der partei auf jeden
fall weil er die leute aktiviert also
die leute müssen ja aktiviert werden und
das werden sie dadurch
es wird ihnen vermittelt dass das ernst
genommen wird dass man sie hört dass
ihre fragen stellen können
das problem ist nicht die person die an
der spitze steht sondern es muss möglich
der neue kurs auch umgesetzt und dann
habe ich ein gutes gefühl dass wir die
größe wieder bekommen die die spd hatte
alle kandidaten versprechen sich hinter
den siegern einzureihen
was auch sonst noch immer gibt es keinen
klaren favoriten
es gibt was neues vom zoll und
handelsstreit zwischen usa und china den
größten wirtschaftsmächte der erde
gestern abend deutscher zeit schien
einen sonnenstrahl aus den dunklen
wolken zu blitzen eine teileinigung vor
läuft noch nicht im detail geregelt und
ohnehin nur ein erster schritt aber die
kapitalmärkte dürften der hat noch was
positiven dass sie einen sprung nach
oben tat weil trump sprach in seiner
zurückhaltenden art von einem lauf fest
einem liebesrausch zwischen den riesen
in des trams schaut heute nochmal genau
wie ein sieger präsentiert sich
präsident trump am abend in louisiana
stolz berichtet er seinen anhängern von
der vereinbarung mit den chinesen gerade
mal ein paar stunden ist die da alt
wichtigste botschaft hier
peking wird den usa wieder mehr
agrargüter abkaufen das kommt an bei der
zielgruppe unsere pharma werden mehr
land kaufen müssen und größere traktoren
ich liebe meine pharma so sehr ich will
dass sie zu mir kommen und sagen du
verlangst zu viel von uns so viel können
wir gar nicht produzieren ich aber sage
ihnen ich habe china dazu gebracht ganz
viel bei euch zu bestellen
die vom handelskrieg gebeutelten pharma
sollen sich freuen die chinesen
versprechen sojabohnen und schweine im
wert von 40 oder 50 milliarden dollar
abzunehmen auch ihren bankenmarkt zu
öffnen und diebstahl geistigen eigentums
schärfer zu unterbinden
doch vieles bleibt vage nach den
zweitägigen verhandlungen mit der
chinesischen delegation trump ist mit
der ukraine affäre unter druck er will
einem erfolg und sei es einen kleinen
hatte er zuvor noch einen großen wurf
gefordert rechtfertigt er nun dieses
teilabkommen als phase 1 der große deal
soll doch so viele aspekte umfassen da
finde ich es besser es in bereiche und
phasen einzuteilen
tram feiert die zusagen der chinesen als
großartig im gegenzug wird der
bestehende zölle auf chinesische waren
nicht wie angedroht in der kommenden
woche erhöhen
der chinesische vize premier
vorsichtiger in der bewertung
wir sind uns einig die us chinesischen
wirtschaftsbeziehungen zu verbessern das
ist gut für china die usa und die
gesamte welt wir machen gute
fortschritte in die richtige richtung
eine absichtserklärung eine waffenpause
im handelskrieg zwischen den präsidenten
hier und trump mehr nicht vertagt sind
streitpunkte wie die staatshilfen für
chinesische unternehmen
ein brief für trump mit den besten
grüßen von dem einen droht ein
amtsenthebungsverfahren dem anderen
immer neue demonstrationen in hongkong
erscheint beide wollen den streit
deeskalieren
es geht um den weltfrieden es gab große
zerwürfnisse zwischen uns und china aber
jetzt haben wir ein liebes fest das ist
eine gute sache
lamberti mitte november treffen offen ob
die mündliche vereinbarung bis dahin
tatsächlich unterschriftsreif sein wird
verschrifteten bislang nichts
die nachrichten von gundula gause
beginnen mit dem konflikt der jederzeit
sehr viel größer werden kann als er
jetzt schon ist
im streit über die türkische militär
offensive in nordsyrien haben die usa
der türkei den beschuss amerikanische
soldaten vorgeworfen
das türkische verteidigungsministerium
weist das zurück
es seien keine us kräfte beschossen
worden zugleich meldet die türkei sie
habe eine strategisch wichtige
grenzstadt eingenommen
das allein war bislang unter kontrolle
der kurden milizen
menschenrechtsaktivisten bestätigten die
ankunft der türkischen truppen in der
stadt wie viele menschen bei den kämpfen
seit mittwoch ums leben kamen ist unklar
nach ersten angaben sind es 28
zivilisten und 45 kämpfer vor dem
hintergrund der türkischen
militäroffensive in nordsyrien wird die
bundesregierung keine weiteren
rüstungsexporte in die türkei genehmigen
aus minister mars bestätigte neue
genehmigungen würden nicht erteilt in
deutschland beteiligten sich tausende an
friedlichen protestaktionen gegen die
militäroffensive wie hier in hamburg
forderten die überwiegend kurdischen
demonstranten ein ende der angriffe
weitere hintergründe auf heute.de nach
dem rechtsextremistischen terroranschlag
von halle hat bayerns ministerpräsident
die afg heftig angegriffen und ihr
heuchelei vorgeworfen
die afg sei auf dem weg die ware npd zu
sein sagte der csu chef vor der jungen
union
afg vorstand leuten wehrt sich gegen
schuldzuweisungen
es sei beschämend dass im zusammenhang
mit dieser schrecklichen tat eine solche
politische instrumentalisierung beginnen
in sachsen haben nun auch die grünen für
die aufnahme von koalitionsverhandlungen
mit cdu und spd gestimmt
oder den sächsischen grünen gibt es
zweifel grüne ziele in einer so
genannten kenia koalition durchzusetzen
verhandlungen mit cdu und spd seien aber
die einzige realistische alternative
damit die afd nicht an die macht komme
nach tagelangen unruhen in ekuador
zeichnet sich offenbar entspannung ab
anführer der protestbewegung sagten sie
seien zu gesprächen mit präsident moreno
bereit gleichzeitig kam es heute wieder
zu unruhen als vermummte vermutlich eine
splittergruppe ein regierungsgebäude in
der hauptstadt quito verwüsten
die proteste richten sich gegen die
sparpolitik der regierung die zu stark
gestiegenen benzinpreise geführt hat
morgen wählt polen ein neues parlament
die europäische union hat große probleme
damit wie die regierung dort mit dem
rechtsstaat umgeht mit einer justiz die
immer abhängiger wird vom willen der
regierung mit öffentlich rechtlichen
sendern an ganz kurz alleine mit
diskriminierung gegen minderheiten als
regierungspolitik und trotzdem wird
morgen die pis mit abstand die meisten
stimmen bekommen
die partei des jaroslaw kaczynski der
kein staatsamt hat aber die macht im
staat
wir haben unsere korrespondentin den
warschauer gefragt wie das sein kann
polen waren doch die mutigen eisbrecher
des kalten krieges sind aufgestanden für
demokratie so wütend fallen in polen
dieser tage meinungsäußerungen aus in
ihren händen hat ja wieder die auflagen
starke liberale tageszeitung gazeta
wyborcza
das interessiert mich nicht ich werde
natürlich für die pis stimmen
es ist eine bemerkenswerte aktion die
polarisiert eine zeitung macht offenen
wahlkampf gegen die pis und lässt eine
million gratis exemplare verteilt
es ist eine spezielle vorwahl zeitung in
der auf all die schlechten taten die
regierung und deren propaganda
hingewiesen wird
polen tief gespalten omnipräsent im
wahlkampf der pis übervater parteichef
kaczynski die nationalkonservativen
liegen laut umfragen bei mindestens 40
die versprechen leicht zu verstehen mehr
geld für familien rentner höherer
mindestlohn
unser polen ist eines mit einem großen
sozialprogramme in polen mit einem
großen wirtschaftsprogramm ein polen
dass die traditionellen werte verteidigt
das kommt vor allem im ärmeren osten
polens an wie in die abbott laska für
die leute hier hat die pis geliefert
allen voran das kindergeld eingeführt
anja bekommt für jedes ihrer drei kinder
umgerechnet etwa 115 euro im monat
das kindergeld hat den familien mit
vielen kindern sehr geholfen
das ist doch echtes geld warschau und
die große politik sind 150 kilometer weg
dass die pis nach dem letzten wahlsieg
umgehend die öffentlich rechtlichen
medien und das verfassungsgericht unter
ihre kontrolle gebracht hat ist in
biasca offenbar nicht waren entscheidend
dafür interessiere ich mich nicht ich
habe mit gericht nichts zu tun
da habe ich keine meinung die pis setzt
auf soziale wohltaten und macht stimmung
gegen mehr rechte für homosexuelle
kaczynski ist eng vernetzt mit erz
konservativen kirchenvertretern die
geben seit wochen wahlkampfhilfe erlaubt
es nicht dass das böse von gender und lg
bietet polen überschwemmt und die herzen
und köpfe der polen vergällt
darüber ist ein kultur kampf
ausgebrochen immer mehr gleichheits
paraden unter großem polizeischutz
wütende gegner zielen auf mit
eindeutigen gesten es gab auch gewalt
die oppositionelle bürger koalition
wirbt für toleranz und will die justiz
wieder politisch unabhängig machen sie
liegt bei etwa 22 prozent
wir werden sehr bald sehr wichtige
entscheidungen treffen
sie werden unser leben beeinflussen dass
unsere kinder unsere enkel die linke im
moment überhaupt nicht im sem vertreten
setzt auf einen antiklerikalen kurs ist
pro homo-ehe und liegt bei 13 prozent
die pis wird wohl der wahlsieger die
entscheidende frage ist wird sie die
absolute mehrheit verteidigen und polen
weiter reformieren wie sie es nennt der
außergewöhnlich heftige taifun roke ibis
hat japan erreicht und schwere schäden
angerichtet
in mehreren regionen des landes am
sinnflutartigen regenfällen
überflutungen und erdrutsche ausgelöst
mindestens zwei menschen kamen bislang
ums leben millionen sollen sich in
sicherheit bringen
in der hauptstadt tokio ist das
öffentliche leben weitgehend lahmgelegt
vor dem sportstudio ist eine
spitzenleistung zu melden
zum ersten mal ist ein mensch einen
marathon in weniger als zwei stunden
gelaufen
in wien hat der kenianer eliud kipchoge
eine stunde 59 minuten und 40 sekunden
für die gut 42 kilometer gebraucht er
selbst hält den offiziellen weltrekord
von knapp über zwei stunden aufgestellt
beim marathon in berlin
heute in wien wurde nicht als weltrekord
anerkannt weil die bedingungen vom
veranstalter perfektioniert worden waren
das entspricht nicht den regeln des
leichtathletik weltverbandes
die lottozahlen lauten diesmal wie immer
ohne gewähr
4 23 36 42 44 45 superzahl 7 mehr auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text das
herbstwetter wird noch mal wärmer morgen
zeigt sich fast überall die sonne nur im
nordwesten und an den küsten gibt es
viele wolken und zeitweise etwas regen
örtlich auch gewitter bei 17 bis 27 grad
und auch zu wochenbeginn ist es im süden
und osten sonnig und warm regnen wird es
nur im nordwesten ab mittwoch wird es
wieder unbeständiger und kühler
aber wie gesagt es geht gut los wir
wünschen einen schönen sonntag und sind
am abend dann hier
[Musik]